this video from November 2018 shows a
holding facility near the small Russian
town of Nicosia where government
officials are investigating the
capturing and exporting of wild beluga
whales and orcas
this is footage of the same facility
taken in January of 2019 the companies
holding the animals captive claim that
they will be sent to aquariums for
educational purposes but animal rights
activists say that they were captured
illegally and suspect that they will be
sent to amusement parks in China
government prosecutors have halted all
exports from the facility until further
notice On January 18th and 19th Russian
border guards brought in a team of
scientists to gather footage of the
facility and to assess the health of the
marine mammals analysis by Jeff foster a
biologist who reviewed the photos
suggest that the 11 orcas and 87 belugas
at the facility are now in declining
health
[Music]
ice must be shoveled out of the belugas
enclosures to keep the water from
freezing over if the water freezes the
juvenile belugas won't be able to
breathe at the surface and will
eventually drown
according to foster some of the orcas
appear to have developed a skin
condition often associated with exposure
to excessive cold
[Music]
a lawyer for one of the companies
holding the animals insisted that they
were caught legally with the required
government permits and would only be
released on court orders
environmentalists have now filed a
lawsuit with the goal of returning the
orcas and belugas back into the wild
as the investigation continues and
severe cold persists activists fear it
will be too late for the animals if they
are not released immediately
but for now they remain frozen in legal
limbo
[Music]
[Music]